[Music]
Amazon CloudWatch is a monitoring
service for AWS cloud resources and the
applications you run on AWS cloud watch
enables monitoring for ec2 and other
Amazon cloud services so you can get
alerts when things go wrong you can use
Amazon CloudWatch to collect and track
metrics so you can get system-wide
visibility into resource utilization
application performance and overall
operational health and you can use these
insights to react and keep your
applications running smoothly car watch
offers two types of monitoring there's
basic monitoring which is included free
of charge and polls every five minutes
and gives you ten metrics five gigabytes
of data ingestion and five gigabytes of
data storage then this detailed
monitoring and this costs more as a
price per instance per month but it
pulls every minute so if you want more
detailed monitoring than you can pay for
it
AWS cloud watch allows you to record
metrics for services such as EBS ec2
elastic load balancer and Amazon s3 and
using these metrics you can add them to
dashboards to give visual or text-based
notifications of what's going on and
this is a diagram of a bit dashboard in
Amazon CloudWatch metrics are at the
hypervisor level so you can get things
like CPU disk network you cannot see
memory usage metrics appear as you add
more resources to your AWS account you
can create events based on your card
watch monitoring for example triggering
lambda functions so perhaps if you need
es volume fills up you could trigger an
event so that data is removed and
archived from the volume or a new volume
is created so there's many things you
can do you can install cloud watch
agents on ec2 instances and this will
send monitoring data about the instance
to cloud watch so you can monitor things
like HTTP response codes
Apache or you can count exceptions in
application logs you can set alarms to
warn based on resource usage for example
if CPU utilization is too high then it
could send a notification it can also
auto scale so if your CPU is maxed out
you can get another instance launched to
take care of some of the load or you can
send cloud watch monitoring alarms to
ec2 actions to say recover an instance
or reboot an instance if something
happens you can also use alarms to shut
down instances it isn't just used for
starting them up so if you have idle
instances you can get cloud watch to
shut them down for you in this
demonstration we're going to take a look
at AWS cloud watch and how we can use it
to shutdown idle instances
so before I start
ministration I launched an Amazon Linux
incidence and let it run for 10 minutes
just so we'd have some data so now I'm
going to go to management tools and
click on cloud Watch and this brings us
to the cloud watch dashboard so what
we're going to do is we're going to
create a new dashboard and we'll click
on create dashboard so that we can have
a look at the monitoring statistics for
our new instance so let's just give it a
name and we'll call it just simply learn
just for a change
okay so there's create dashboard and now
we get the option do we want to put text
base or metric graphs widgets to our
dashboard and we're going to select
metric graphs so we'll click on
configure and then we're presented with
all the cloud box metrics that I have
available in my AWS account so obviously
I've just launched an ec2 instance so
I'm going to click on ec2 metrics and my
new server is called simply Zurn cloud
watch demo so I want to add CPU
utilization let's click on that so let
me create this widget and then that now
appears on our dashboard so we can add
more so we click on add widget will do
another metric graph will go another per
instance metric and let's choose network
in and network out and we'll create the
widget now as you can see there's not a
lot happening here because I just
launched this instance and I haven't
really done anything on it but this is
how you would create a dashboard and
it's quite useful and very easy to see
so you can create a dashboard for your
instance types
so what we're also going to do is set up
an alarm so let's go to alarms so now we
want to create an alarm so we click on
create alarm and we get to choose the
metric glue on the base the alarm on now
obviously we have an ec2 instance so
we're going to choose that option I'm
going to do it based on CPU utilization
of our simply learned cloud watch demo
instance so we'll click on that and
we'll click Next so now we get to give
our alarm a name so just going to call
this simply learn underscore alarm just
for the purposes of this demo we can
give
description and now we get to set the
alarm threshold so we're saying whenever
CPU utilization is and we're going to
say less than or equal to 50% for one
consecutive period and remember a period
is five minutes in basic monitoring we
want this alarm to fire so why would you
do this well imagine if you had a really
high-powered server that we're using
every night to do some highly intensive
compute computations so you might know
that it runs for a couple of hours and
it's charging you quite a lot of money
per hour to run but when the CPU
utilization drops below say fifty
percent or ten percent you know the job
is complete so then you can get an alarm
to fire and an action to happen so you
could set a notification so we could
together to send an email when this
alarm fires we're not going to do that
in this demonstration but we can do an
ec2 action so whenever this state is in
alarm I want it to stop this instance so
this instance is going to be stopped
whenever the CPU utilization is less
than 50% for five minutes
and it's just telling us that there so
now if I click on create alarm and here
is our alarm so it's just telling us
we're in alarm already because this
instance has been up and running it has
monitoring data for the last five
minutes and it's saying the alarm has
fired let me click on it and we'll see
why so it's take change to alarm reason
threshold crossed one data point point
zero zero three four was less than equal
to the threshold at 50% and it says when
it's in alarm it's going to stop the
instance so if we go to the ec2
dashboard and here we can see that the
simply learn cloud works demo instance
has been stopped and it's in the status
of alarm so telling us that our alarm
fired and it took it straight down
obviously that's a pretty dramatic
example you wouldn't expect anything
like that to happen in a real world but
it's a good way of seeing how alarms
work
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing quick here